it's time for jews news your daily crack
of those good news knuckles and with me
at the desk is a man who wouldn't say
that's his favorite sound it's ross
matthews yes it is
we get started today is the grand finale
of pop quiz win
my favorite
well at the end of the show someone from
our audience is getting in that money
booth and going to town that's right
look at that money booth right there
you need
you need to pay attention all so long
because you're going to answer questions
about today's episode and earn time in
that booth and guess what there's ten
thousand dollars in there
one of you have a chance to grab
all right well let's get right into the
headlines ross because i'm not gonna
even pretend to fake it give it to me
now well this is the relationship we
didn't know we needed but we do and it's
a saucy update to a story we talked to
earlier this week we told you that kim
kardashian and pete davidson they're
just friends right even though we saw
this picture from people magazine them
holding hands on a roller coaster well
now drew page six reports they were
spotted again
uh you know i'm obsessed they were set
seen separately at the manhattan club
zero bond and then the night before that
they shared a private rooftop dinner
in staten island where p is from the
king of staten island yes pete got kim
kardashian to go to staten island
and we do hear that he pete called and
reserved the whole rooftop which you
don't do for someone who's just a friend
am i right or am i right i'm right i've
been on the other side of it there's
nothing worse than when you're trying to
get to know someone and everyone else is
making it their business so
i have apologize that i'm horrified and
i have get why everybody's excited about
it yeah uh-huh i simultaneously want to
keep my distance and be respectful and
sorry
not sorry
so um we're gonna keep our little finger
on the pulse of this story and keep you
updated all right hey an update on
something else we've been following too
we've been freaking out okay over the
the sneak peeks of kristen stewart as
princess diana and the new biopic
spencer remember when they announced it
i said on this show she's going to be
nominated for an oscar and guess what
the reviews are in they are saying she
is stellar and the movie is out today
take a look at christian foot as
princess zion
[Music]
[Music]
they know everything
they don't
and the winner is
i mean she's totally going to be
nominated for an oscar for this right i
will say um again being on the other
side of it you know you work so hard for
these roles and sometimes nothing comes
out of them and sometimes they do i have
been in this business since i was in
diapers i've never been nominated for an
academy award we you go out there and
you try really hard and i'm so happy
when people's efforts get recognized and
i wish this for her she's been working
in this business since she was a child
and she's really amazing and let this be
her moment i think she's really worked
for it and she totally heard that
totally
i
i
am really excited for her i we've all
gone on her journey and watched her grow
up in front of our very eyes
and i am rooting for her i really am
this looks incredible and i can't wait
to see it i'm going to see it this
weekend and by the way she just got
engaged too that's right congratulations
congratulations
[Applause]
okay next we've got good news from
norway
the cut reports that the norwegian
women's beach handball team won their
battle yeah
this generation has changed its rules
and now the women can wear tank tops and
shorts just like the men
except it's still stipulated that the
women's shorts must be tight
uh-huh
yeah
steps steps baby steps stop steps this
is phenomenal news and good for them i
will say
okay i worked at mcdonald's and i was uh
driveway register and grill which we
call the triple threat and i had to wear
a hat and i at the end of every shift
would have hat hair and the girls got to
wear a visor and i fought all the way up
to the regional manager named steve you
know who you are and i thought and i won
the right to wear a visor i know
you
you heard of
you heard of norma ray i was like norma
gay give me advisor and that's i mean
that's a silly stupid story but this
this is amazing what they did because
why are we living in a time where they
need to wear a bikini to compete you
don't wear whatever you want to wear to
compete right i think it's honoring to
listen to the players yeah and not tell
them what they have to do but honor what
it is they need to do
all right well it was just halloween and
thanksgiving is around the corner but to
us every day is a reason to celebrate so
there's national cheese curd day there
is i didn't know that
apparently there is
poutine
there is national noodle day
and there's national produce misting day
oh wow
i missed that day oh my god
i know you said oh yes i did that worked
really well did you you just just right
now i just missed it just on top of my
head gosh
um well those were all last month but
guess what we're starting a new segment
to make sure that we don't miss the
chance to celebrate and we're going to
call it every day's holidays
[Applause]
well so i bet you're all wondering
what's today well i'll fill you in it's
national donut day
thank you so much oh my gosh look how
many donuts here
this is amazing
and these we've got donuts from donut
makers across the country who brought
these in from right here in new york
city we've got the donut project thank
you so much
and then from chicago hey chicago we
have donuts from fire cakes
those look oh my god so good
and from drew from your hometown los
angeles we've got donuts from the donut
king right there
famous donut king
can i ask what am i going to have i want
this this guy what's your favorite donut
of all time like
the one you're eating now
simple simple no filling no oh you don't
like a filling oh no oh really i like it
when they're a little fruity
[Laughter]
well
before we go i would like to give you a
pick from the little yellow book which
is my personal curation of things i
thought maybe you might enjoy as well
it's on our website we refresh it every
week and today it is the perfect pick
for national donut day it's the donut
king which is the documentary
and you can watch it right now
on hulu
and if you love learning about where
food and culture intersect this one is
for you it dives into the incredible
history of the donut in california and
how the cambodian community
that is at the heart of this and changed
the entire game it drove out big
business
literally the entire california donut
industry is run by all of these
transplants from cambodia and it's just
an incredible story i hope you enjoy it
and thank you so much
[Music]
you